-Finally, I'm very excited about this.
Super Bowl LVII is happening this Sunday.
You have the Philadelphia Eagles...
[ Cheers and applause ]
...facing off against the Kansas City Chiefs.
Now, as you know, after the game,
they give out awards like Most Valuable Player,
but they also give out awards before the game, too.
Did you know that? -No, I did not.
-Yeah, they do. I'll show you what I mean.
It's time for "Tonight Show Superlatives."
Here we go.
-♪ Tonight Show Superlatives ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Our first player is from the Chiefs.
It's their quarterback, Patrick Mahomes.
He was voted...
[ Applause ]
Next up, from the Eagles is quarterback Jalen Hurts.
He was voted...
"What's up, man? Can I help you?"
"Yeah, I guess Charlotte lives here."
Next up, from the Chiefs is Tommy Townsend.
He was voted...
Oh, is that...?
-Hey.
-Yeah, that's him.
Next up, from the Chiefs is Andrew Wylie.
He was voted...
[ Laughs ]
-Chug Lord. -Chug Lord. That's a title.
-Next up, from the Chiefs is Nick Allegretti.
He was voted...
That's very hard to do. Not easy.
Next up, from the Chiefs is Creed Humphrey.
He was voted...
[ Laughter and applause ]
Next up, from the Eagles is Jake Elliott.
He was voted...
[ Laughter and applause ]
"Come on over here. He's just the cutest little thang."
And finally, from the Chiefs is Noah Gray.
He was voted...
There you have it, everybody. Those are your Superlatives.